les masques bild on s'est demandé où la
première ministre de l'alberta prenait
ses chiffres pour défendre le projet
trans mountain le projet de france
montrent une consiste à doubler un
pipeline qui relie and maintain à
barnabé tout près de vancouver pour
défendre le projet le gouvernement de
l'alberta mais aussi celui du canada
disent que la construction de ce
pipeline devrait générer 15 mille
emplois directs ou indirects dans
l'ouest du pays
ce chiffre de 15 mille emplois est tiré
d'une étude du conference board du
canada
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que l'étude
du conference board du canada a été
commandée et payée par craintes mountain
en fait ce que les dirigeants des
transhumants tonnes ont dit devant
l'office national de l'énergie
c'est que c'est en moyenne 2500
personnes qui auraient travaillé
directement sur la construction du
pipeline par une période d'environ trois
ans tout le reste ce sont des emplois
indirects générés par les retombées
économiques
une fois en service ont dit que le
pipeline 13000 tonnes devraient générer
37 mille emplois sur un horizon de 20
ans mais s'agit presque entièrement
d'emplois indirects
parce que selon ressources naturelles
canada l'exploitation du pipeline trans
manten devrait nécessiter tout au plus
440 travailleurs à temps plein
[Musique]